[Music]
is a concept about which we now
frighteningly live
your desecration of reality
it was the only way
[Applause]
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
so
later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for i need your
help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry stephen
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
every night
i dream the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
it doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Music]
you